et bien bonjour comment ça va nous sommes aujourd'hui avec
La casa de papel
Nan, bah non
La casa de Papel
La série.
Mais où est la maison de la monnaie à ce moment là ?
Ah ouais non en fait j'ai regardé...
ET C'ETAIT MCFLYYYYYYYY!!!!
ET C'ETAIT MCFLYYYYYYYY !!!!
(McFly) AHHHH OUIIIII !!
Il est où Raph?
Il est où Raph? x2
Ah mec je vois rien du tout
* La fille fait figure de surdouée de l'adaptation, elle a atteint des sommets dans l'art de la contrefaçon*
*Voix off*
*OH, Il était là !*
(Carlito) AHHHHHHHHH!!!
(Tout le monde) AHHHHHHHHHH!!!
*le cri qui dure 1000 ans...*
Il est là le Jim Carrey de YouTube !
le combat du siècle
La vidéo...
*PAF*
La vidéo n'a que...
*Pauvre David qui voulait parler de la vidéo... :(*
La vidéo n'a que 20 secondes
REGARDEZ-MOI CA !
*lol squeezie est facile a se faire soulever*
AHHHH! *criant comme un Corbeau*
La vidéo a 20 secondes
Bienvenue à tous
Ces vidéos sont des genre de catharisis
Un exutoire c'est-a-dire que...
MAIS FERME-LAA PUT...!!!!
*Rire de squeezie*
Bon les amis, on arrête la casse
de papel
Nous somme réunis ici
Non pas pour prier dieu
Mais pour ouvrir déballer certain
un T
un
un... o_o ?
*clap* Le numéro...
UN Quasiment bientôt numéro 1
a échoué mesdames et messieurs
Nan les gars LES GARS !
les gars
SAUUUUT A LA PERRRCHE!!!!
*la perche craque* HAHAHAHA
Les amis
Je ne suis pas retourné au Japon depuis la dernière fois
Toi ? tu manges une madeleine dans ma vidéo ?
- Des madeleines Saint-Michel*Beau placement de produit*
AHH
Est-ce que vous pensez que cette madeleine peut rentrer dans mon nez?
- C'est du gâchis
Bravo
Oh attend il a fait une super...
Oh tu pouvais pas faire mieux
Dans cette vidéo, vous voyez ce genre de gags ?
Il va y'en avoir beaucoup.
Puisqu'aujourd'hui nous allons déballer des objets de farces et attrapes !!!
(Mcfly) Farces et attrapes...
(Mcfly) Ce mot...
(Squeezie) J'suis le seul a être enthousiaste ?
(Carlito) Le concept le plus simple...
Les farces et attrapes et moi, c'est une grande histoire d'amour
Ceci est...
(Mcfly) De la moutarde
Est ce que tu peux ouvrir s'il te plaît ?
AHHH !
*Objet non identifié*
Non ! Fais pas c.. c'est de la moutarde
C'est tout ?
(Squeezie) Oui... HAHAHAHAHAAAAAAAAAAAA ! (?)
Regardez bien. Le Diamond Button
Regardez bien ça ces deux objets côte à côte. C'est ca. C'est ça YouTube aujourd'hui...
Vous l'aurez compris dans cette vidéo je réalise un rêve d'enfant
J'ai acheté beaucoup de farces et attrapes
Lâche cette b***.
et on va les ouvrir ensemble avec Mcfly et Carlito
Moi je sais les objets que j'ai pris mais eux ils le savent pas donc on va leur faire découvrir
Y'a des objets je vais les ramener vous en aurez entendu parler toute votre vie et enfin vous l'aurez devant vous
Comme par exemple a u...une relation sexuelle...
avec une femme consentante...
*Continuons la vidéo*
Comme dans chaque vidéo où on déballe des objets y'a une tradition qui a été mise en place qui s'appelle ?
LES COSTUMES !!
OUAIIIIIIIIS !!!!!
Ah bon ? On a fait ça ?
oui y'a un... dac...ouais Ouais ouais... Qui veut mettre son costume en premier ?
AAAAAAAAHHHH !!
Ha ha non arrête
Est ce que vous saviez que ceci existait?
Ha non
Aaaaaaahhhhh
La maturité elle est définie par quoi ? Tu vois les gens nous disent à nous
"ah bon vous avez deux enfants ah bah dit donc"
Mais on paye des impôts, il a une maison de campagne, on travaille dur, la vaisselle c'est pas la meuf qui fait c'est tout le monde qui fait
Il y a un ensemble
Du point de vu du logis, domestique, du ménage, relation familiale...
Je me fais chier
*McFly arrive avec le costume*
Ah HA HA
Il a pas mit ce trous là l'homme dedans est déjà très large donc le costume ne l'est plus
Pour moi il est ma taille
Raph ?
Ouais ?
à demain, oh non j'adore
De toute façon dés qu'on a une tête comme ça dans la vidéo c'est... j'adore
Ba la t'as ta vignette hein quasiment on va faire une petite pose
Bon Raph c'est long la
*La maturité 0*
*bon bah...rien a dire hein?*
*même McFly en peut plus...*
Imaginez, mes enfants plus grands
Ils disent, "Au fait, ton travail c'est quoi ?"
Bam ! Extrait
AH HAHAHAHAHA
Mec, est ce que on peut dire que c'est la pire réplique de flûte jamais vu quoi ?
Tout est la pire réplique
Oh mais merde...
Putain c'est ouf c'est clair c'est énorme quoi
*tu peut me dire le goût du serpent stp mcfly?*
Non mais c'est pas...
Ca va sexuellement heu..
Non mais là j'ai fait...
BON les gars il manque un costume
Il veut zoué le zerpent nanana... ah bou bou bou ah bou bou le zerpent
Le petit calin du serpent
*Squeezie arrive avec le costume....*
Mais il rendait mieux en photo quand même
Les Japonais sont tellement meilleurs que les français en gag
Y'a même pas de... Comment on appelle ça ? La petite racine verte la ?
Si elle est là
Tu l'avais même pas mit, il a même pas fait l'effort
ok att... AH HAHA !!
Le dos !
Peut-être puis-je avoir l'aide de l'un de vous deux ? Sans spoil le troisième
Ah bah moi je regarde ailleurs, je regarde dans cette direction
C'est une direction euh... parfaite.
Là ça va être l'éclate mec
ok.. haha
Vous allez voir celui la c'est l'éclate c'est...
Vous vous rappelez de Jackasse ?
Ah ouais, allez je me prépare psychologiquement..
T'es prêt à délirer? On va peter un plomb..on va être hyper, ça va nous turn up
David ? Tu veux une petite photo de toi David ? Pour mémoriser cette vidéo
Moui...
Ca a pas marché...
Avec un ÉNORME e
C'est censé être un appareil photo qui envoie de l'eau
Ca ce qui est important c'est de.. d'en faire attention
Lucas c'était...
Oh t'as une clope ? Tu veux te fumer un peu.. Une petite clope ?
AAAHHHHH !!
PUTAIIIIIIINN !!!
LE PREMIER GAG QUI A MARCHE !!! OUIII !!!
Qu'est ce que c'est ? Qu'est ce que c'est ça fait de l'électricité c'est ça ?
Oh c'est horrible ! Y'a que moi qui ai eu mal et les gens n'ont rien vu, c'est vraiment la pire chose..
Les gars j'ai un bail génial
Petit extrait des bails géniaux qu'il y'a eu dans cette vidéo déjà...
Les amis est ce que vous connaissez cet objet ?
Un dentier qui... s'agite tout seul lorsqu'on le pose sur une table
On va s'éclater...
Ouais Lucas... Ca va ?
On connait ouais ouais on connait
Ba euhhh... Aujourd'hui on l'a en vrai !
Ooooohh ! Enfin tu veux dire ?!
Profitez c'est sans doute le meilleur moment de toute la vidéo
Non mais les gars fin... regardez regardez je vous le refais bien
haha.. c'est un peu drôle au bout d'un moment
Désolé les gars, les meilleurs Youtubeurs de France...
Et on assiste à une déchéance totale...
Bon les gars ! ça fait lon... ça fait longtemps qu'on a pas ouvert un petit pot
Qui veut l'ouvrir ?
Avec plaisir
Tu peux secouer pour voir ce que c'est
Oh y'a des petites peanuts, des petites cacahuètes
Des cacahuètes évidemment
C'est même plus... C'est même plus une teub ou un truc... Regarde bien
Est ce qu'on peut remettre cette séquence au ralenti s'il vous plaît ?
Est ce que vous savez ce que c'est que ça ?
Ce serait pas du poil à gratter par ex..euh par hasard ?
Qui veut tester le poil...
MCFLY !
Enculé...
Ca se présente comme du.. du poil ?
T'es prêt ?
Ba ouais...
Bon les gars, qui n'a jamais rêvé d'avoir cet objet ?
Attention essayez de deviner
Tu le voulais quand t'étais en cours absolument cet objet
Je savais pas trop si c'était une légende ou s'il existait vraiment
Le stylo qui efface et qui réécrit ?
Non...
Le stylo qui écrit tout seul ?
Le stylo avec des...des...dedans les...
Ah
Les antisèches
Ah j'allais dire des parents pas séparés
Vous n'avez jamais rêvé d'avoir ce stylo ?
Sii sii... Ah waw..on peut écrire...
Lucas ça va ? Ca va mec ?
Ouais de ouf..
T'es bien ?
Non mais après on peut parler de mes soucis peut-être après fin...
Les vacances ? C'était bien les vacances ?
Ouais ouais cool...
La la rentrée ça se passe, j'ai vu les 10 millions, la vidéo...
T'as trouvé une direction là qui déchire sur Youtube, les gens ils kiffent
T'entends les gens qui disent "t'as vu ce qu'il fait"
Ouais mais ça c'est dans la lignée tu vois c'est genre les gens ils apprennent des trucs
Ils découvrent des choses et puis de manière ludique, ils s'amusent
Qu'est-ce qui t'arrives sur cette p*tain de vidéo Lucas?
Pourquoi t'as commandé de la merde? - Mais pourquoi tu prends ce ton?
Ah si si attends comment tu sais? Oh t'as regardé dans le carton
Comment t'as fait pour savoir avant que je l'amène celui-là?
Oh la non...
Je rêvais d'un faux caca étant plus jeune (?)
Est-il réaliste ? Ah il est pas mal !
Il est mou ou pas? Je peux montrer l'envers du décor?
Venez on fait comme si on marchait sur du caca!!
OH MCFLY VIENS VOIR! Y A UN MASQUE
OH NOON MINCE J'AI MARCHE DANS LA MERDE MAIS DU PIED GAUCHE CA PORTE BONHEUR
C'est un pistolet à prout !
La tristesse d'un homme
Regarde tu fais ça en appuyant sur le ventre
Oh mais c'est un coussin péteur !
Nan les gars je vous ai mytho,
voici le nouvel objet climax de la vidéo
Souffle dans cet objet - Je vais rien me prendre dans la gueule? - Nan promis
*Rires et chutes de Mcly et Carlito*
Rien ne marche !
Je suis en train de les tuer hahaha
J'ai des vertiges les gars
Les gars! On a rien mangé ce matin, tenez - Oh cool merci
Oh cool des caramelos tutti frutti
Attention répondez bien
Je vais ouvrir cette boîte
J'en ai ras le cul
Je vais commencer à casser des trucs
La vidéo je vais l'appeler "Essayez de pas quitter le tournage"' - Nan mets "Essayez de rire"
Les gars je peux vous dire un truc pour de vrai? Le prochain objet gros
Nan nan cette fois vraiment!! (x3) C'est le rêve de toute une vie
J'en faisais des faux avec mon frère
en alliant deux trucs mais je vais pas dire parce qu'il y a des jeunes qui vont reproduire et j'ai pas envie qu'ils le fassent
Qu'est-ce que c'est Lucas? - Voici des vrais fumigènes
Bonne idée plutot bonne idée! - Alors est-ce qu'à votre avis ils marchent?
Parce que ça vient du même site que le reste - Je vous lis un petit peu les éléments comme ça qu'il y a d'écrit
"A n'utiliser que dans un espace bien aéré"
et attention "allumez à bout de bras à l'aide d'une allumette"
Alors j'explique un truc, mon bureau c'est l'ancien fumoir du batiment
Donc avec un peu de chance ils ont jamais réactivé les détecteurs de fumée
C'est d'ailleurs pour ça que la dernière fois quand on avait fait des feux d'artifice dans le bureau, ça n'avait rien déclenché
J'espère! Si je me trompe on est mort - Allez (x3)
*chuchote* Par contre il va falloir le controler, avec la fumée, il va un peu
Quoi? Vous avez dit quoi? - Nan rien t'inquiète
On allume un seul pour le moment? - Vous êtes prêts les gars?
Deuxième chance
*Renifle*
Non Carlito
MEC MEC MEC MEC
(et c'est reparti mdr il est vraiment ingérable)
Il fait encore sa crise quand il sent de la fumée
A plus Carito
Mais revient pas
Je t'aime !! Je veux me pacser avec toi !!
Bah c'est bon - Heureusement que Carlito s'est barré parce que...
On est comme à la forêt vieux - On est quand même mieux comme ça
Tsais quoi je ferme un peu les yeux là je me mets bien - Ouais pareil on se repose
*Carlito débarque à poil et hurle*
*Musique d'outro* et souscrivez un abonnement